tras una reunión de aproximadamente una
hora y media la presidenta de la
comisión europea aus la von der layen y
el presidente del gobierno de españa
pedro sánchez dieron una corta
declaración en la sede del gobierno
español en madrid inicio el jefe del
ejecutivo español quien calificó al
gobierno de putin de régimen reafirmó el
compromiso y la solidaridad de españa
con ucrania y aseguró que la unión
europea puede contar con el país para
recibir a los refugiados ucranianos
sánchez insistió en que el bloque está
más unido que nunca en su posición de
rechazo al gobierno ruso y recalcó la
necesidad de reforzar las políticas
comunitarias de defensa y de seguridad
que serán en su opinión el complemento
perfecto para una otan cada vez más
relevante por su parte eslabón der layen
aseguró que españa es un socio clave de
la unión sobre todo en el liderazgo del
país en materia de energías renovables
un tema crucial para el futuro
energético del continente ya que la
presidenta de la comisión europea afirmó
la necesidad de dejar atrás la
dependencia de rusia y la importancia de
que la unión europea
diversificar sus fuentes de energía el
viaje el viaje de la líder europea es
parte de una ronda de visitas a varios
países del bloque en preparación a la
cumbre informal el versalles el 10 y 11
de marzo un evento organizado por
francia que ostenta la presidencia
rotativa